[موسيقى]
ورغم ان هرر كان محرما على غير المسلمين
دخولها وكل اهلها يدينون بالاسلام الا ان
للكنائس في هرر حضورها الخاص حيث تحتضن
المدينه المسلمين والمسيحيين جنبا الى جنب
ديانات واعراق عده تمازجت وتجانست دون
الغاء لهويه الاخر فالتسامح هنا في هرر في
اسماء اياته
[موسيقى]
اول ما يلفت الانتباه في تفاصيل هذه
المدينه هي ازقتها الضيقه والبيوت القديمه
الاصيله المشرعه ابوابها وكانها ترحب
بالزائر دون ترقباب
[موسيقى]
تزهو هرر بالالوان فالوان جدران المدينه
وزخرفتها ومنازلها القديمه تنبئ عن حب
الحياه وفي الوقت نفسه فيها شجن وارتباط
بالماضي يابى سكان هذه المدينه ان ينمحي
او ينسى مدينه لها في التاريخ وسام ولكن
على وشك النسيان
[موسيقى]
رغم انه هرر فيها حضاره وتاريخ عميق يعني
كبير الى انه هذه يعني ابتداء حتى من نفسي
انا يعني احس انه صح انا اتيت الى العاصمه
بحثا عن الرزق للحصول على فرص افضل لكن
هناك نتائج سلبيه لهذا القرار يعني ممكن
تحدث فجوه فجوه يعني حضريه انا ما اعرف
اشياء كثيره الان عن بلدي عن هرر عن
تاريخها وممكن حتى عيالي انا ما اقدر انقل
لهم التاريخ كما موجود في الجيل السابع
لذلك يعني انا افضل مثلا لو
الجهات الحكوميه في عرب في اقليم عرب او
حتى رجال الاعمال في هارب وخارج هرب انه
يكون هناك يدعم ويحفزه الشاب انه ما يطلع
لكي لا تندثر هذا لا يندثر هذا التاريخ
[موسيقى]